نحن هنا في واحد من المشافي التابعه
للدوله اي للقطاع العام في هذا المشفى
طبعا ما تراه خلفي هو ليس كله من الناجنه
من هذه المستشفى وهذا قسم العاجل وبالتالي
هناك عده حالات هنا على الارض يمكن ان
نلاحظ تقسيم الخطوط وفق اولويه الحاله
التي تاتي الى هذا المكان وبالتالي سهوله
نقلها عبر هذا المكان الى المناطق الاخرى
سواء كان ذلك لاجراء الفحص بالاشعه او اي
شيء اخر يمكن من خلاله ان يتم
معالجه هذه الحاله وبعد تحقيق الاستقرار
فيها حاله المصاب يتم نقله الى مشافي اكبر
ربما سواء في مدينه انقره او في مدينه
اسطنبول القائمون على هذا المشفى اخبروني
انه اكثر من الفي حاله من المصابين في
كهرما المراش جاءت الى هذا المشفى وتم
تحقيق التدخل الاولي بحيث
تحقيق الاستقرار في الحاله ومن ثم نقلها
الى مشافي اخرى هذه حاله اخرى قد تكون
لحادثه ما ليست ربما من النقاط لكن هي
فرصه لارى ماذا في الداخل كما تشاهد هناك
الكثير من الحالات موجوده في هذا المكان
هناك محاوله لتحقيق الاستقرار في الحالات
وايضا هناك ضغط على هذه الاقسام في هذا
المشفى وهذا الحال هو الحال نفسه في كل
المشافي الاخرى في هذه المناطق اكثر من
الفي حاله كما ذكرت والاطباء اداره المشفى
اخبرتني ان اكثر من 90% من الاطباء في هذه
المشفى تركوا منذ بدايه الزلزال
عائلاتهم وجاوي لهذا المكان ليشاركوا وما
زالوا يشاركون في اعمال الانقاذ ومحاوله
استقرار الحالات ايضا بحسب ما فهمت ان
الوضع الان في العاجل هو استقر نوعا ما
لانه لم يعد هناك الكثير ممن يخرجنا من
تحت الالقاب